bonjour c'est marie hélène bienvenue
dans l'émission les petits bricoleurs
aujourd'hui nous allons réaliser un
masque alors pour cela nous avons besoin
d'un masque d'un carton des feuilles de
la colle de la gouache rouleau de scotch
et un crayon papier
un bateau
un buteur elles sont nées graffeuse un
cutter des ciseaux et décoration des
petites étoiles
alors donc nous allons commencer la
première étape à remettre le le modèle
de masques sur le carton et on prend le
crayon à papier et on fait de contour
là comme ça on fait tout le tour vous
pouvez pas oublier de faire mieux
donc ça donne ça
et maintenant on va découper bon c'est
le carton est trop épais on prend le
cutter qui le quart centre ou ipo peut
prendre avec des ciseaux et l'âge de
croiser locuteurs parce que c'est un
pays paie donc là on va couper tout le
tour
alors donc une fois découpées ça donne
ça
et maintenant on va passer une couche de
pintes de la gouache blanche
une couche de peinture
je mets là dessus sur le papier
toulouse
donc on empêche
donc après avoir peint le masque en rose
voilà le miel est comme ça mais vous
pouvez prendre la forme dont vous voulez
et appelons à le faire tenir avec un
bâton
comme ça
mais voilà
alors donc là on va
voir à graffer les feuilles les formes
de serre moi j'ai choisi ça mais après
vous pouvez prendre d'autres feuilles
dans des tentes dans votre jardin
donc on va bien positionnés les feuilles
on va les agrafes est ensemble
et donc on va fixer sur le mas stes
comme ça
et là on va à graffer aussi
voilà je pense que c'est long ça tiens
voilà ce que ça donne
et maintenant il vous suffit de mettre
des petites décorations manger prévu des
petites étoiles ou des brio j'ai le bail
est né suffit de maintenant je
de décorer votre façon
voilà vous personnalisez votre masque
on peut aussi rajouter des petites
étoiles
voilà du
du doré bleus
alors je vous met une petite tour de
cologne pointe de colle
et toiles la vôtre côté pareil
les pointes de colle et on met la petite
étoile dessus
et voilà notre marque est terminée et à
la prochaine émission